a familiar scene in airports all across
the United States long lines for
canceled flights lost luggage but more
than that missing memories
christening Grace that I was going to
use for my granddaughter which is was
born that we were gonna increase it
again and I'm afraid that that's gonna
get lost and it's possible it's
Priceless which was the greatest
sentimental she's been here every day
looking for her luggage she's not sure
when she'll get it or when her
granddaughter will be baptized everyone
in these long lines has a story to tell
eventually I just left the line after
being told that we probably wouldn't get
a flight to DC until the 28th and paired
up with a family and we all drove
together to
DC and then I stood in line for about
three hours got rebooked for another
flight That was supposed to leave out at
uh probably about nine ish and they say
it okay in about midnight that one was
canceled the severe winter storm saw
almost 20 thousand flights canceled
during the height of the busiest travel
season of the year but most Airlines
have recovered Southwest Airlines a
mostly domestic carrier has canceled the
vast majority of them it's just the fact
that this one started West swept East
and impacted almost every single one of
our largest airports that put us in a
position where we struggled to recover
these lines are not going to get shorter
anytime soon the CEO of Southwest says
they're only going to fly about a third
of their scheduled flights that could
take days Department of Transportation
says it's going to investigate but the
airline's going to have bigger problems
than that everyone I talked to said they
had no intention of following Southwest
Airlines ever again Patty culhane Al
Jazeera Washington